Vegh has set the over-under at five
point five for receivers taken in round
one of the 2020 Draft in the end there
were six so if you bet the over
congratulations Henry rugs the third was
the first one off the board and it's
fitting right Chris paying homage to the
tradition of Al Davis taking the fast
guy the four to seven and the forty from
Henry rugs we talked about that
yesterday and he told me earlier this
week three teams had been contacting him
constantly in the run-up to the draft
the Broncos the 49ers and the Las Vegas
Raiders and you know sometimes the
easiest way to cut through all the smoke
to cut through all the crap to cut
through all the noise is to go straight
to the player and if the player and the
players get the players too young to
understand too naive to realize that
it's this broader shell game right he's
just gonna tell you who he's hurt from
and that's what he did and the Raiders
moved and you know what the fact that he
was so candid about it because she had
the Broncos at 15 you had the 49ers at
13 and at the Raiders sitting there at
12
they probably had to take him when they
did they may have lost him to one of
those two teams well I think that's
right you know I mean you know he was in
high demand so I don't think this is a
surprise to anybody I mean I think
everybody thought he would be one of the
first three receivers off the board we
just didn't know which way it was gonna
go you know with my man John Gurdon
there I wasn't sure if he'd fall in love
with drugs or Jerry Judy I could see
either way because man Gruden could love
him some straight al davis types need
like you talked about but he loves a
route runner like Jerry Rice too and
jerry judy has some of that aspect to
his game but ultimately you know he fell
in love with the weapon he's got his
Tyree kill now this is the type of
player that that Henry rug's is and it
fits I think with what the Raiders want
to do and how they want to play right
they want to run the ball they're gonna
pound the rock from the Josh Jacobs they
have a really awesome offensive line
they got a good tight end they got a
good short or an immediate passing game
we shared derrick karr great completion
percentage now you got a guy who
fly deep down the field that's a good
formula Mike right we talked about that
with offenses all the time offenses that
make you defend the whole field are the
hardest offenses to defend and now with
a guy like this is a deep threat it's a
good intermediate threats in that run
game man the Raiders gonna be a handful
they're gonna be a lot to worry about
assuming Henry rug's works out you know
this is one of the things about the
first night of the draft it always
drives me crazy and I'm not saying that
the analysts should spend time pointing
out hey this guy's really gonna stink I
think the only time that's ever happened
was with Trev Alberts remember that what
the guy said who the hell is Mel Kiper
that was 20 years ago you have great
things about every pic no one ever says
during the first round of the draft you
know history tells us half these guys
are gonna stink right and history tells
us that the receivers who run really
fast at the Scouting Combine more often
than not yeah the next level right so
that's that's part of the risk you
assume when you get smitten with that
straight-line speed the four to seven
that Henry runs the third ran and how
about this three Alabama guys in that
top 15 his quarterback her a quarterback
and his two receivers to talking about
Aloha
Henry rugs and then Jerry Judy at number
15 to the Denver Broncos supposedly the
guy the Broncos wanted all along maybe
Henry rugs was the fallback if Judy was
gone before the Broncos got to number 15
either way they got the guy that there
were rumors they were gonna try to trade
up to get Judy lands with them right at
number 15 and they have now a compliment
to go along with Courtland Sutton
they've got an offense it is really
coming alive with drew Lockett
quarterback no a fan at tight end Melvin
Gordon at running back you still got
Phillip Lindsay in the mix you know yeah
you either fight the Chiefs with a
beefed up defense or you fight the
Chiefs Chris with a beefed up offense
and you're trying to write a track meet
and and that may be what both the
Raiders and the Broncos and to a certain
extent the Chargers by picking the
quarterback we're thinking in round one
last night well definitely you know and
listen I mean great pick by the Denver
Broncos I mean yes I know
Jerry Judy was not my favorite pick in
the draft but still and all
some football player a guy that I
certainly think is capable of having 90
100 110 perceptions in a season and you
know again it's about fit and he really
fits the Denver Broncos you know here's
a route runner you got something to be
sudden to be the deep guy down the field
the back shoulder one-on-one I'm big and
you can't guard me and now you got Judy
to run all the intricate routes let
alone would know a fan and the running
backs you talked about bike I mean
Denver is one of those teams right now
that I'm circling early on because the
defenses are any real you know they
didn't need to spend a whole lot of
assets on that side of the ball you
talked about Bradley Chubb and von
Miller and jerel Casey and they got some
other defensive players and on the front
seven who were impressive that kind of
upcoming AJ Bowie is there
Justin Simmons one of the best safeties
in all of football I mean this is really
turning into a well-rounded football
team who you know I think is gonna be a
force in the AFC now with it with this
type of talent and you know it's funny a
week ago we were debating the question
of whether you would take the Chiefs
roster or a roster of the best players
from the other three teams in the
division the pendulum may have swung
both we're gonna take the Chiefs because
of Patrick mahomes and we still don't
know who the quarterback of this hybrid
Raiders Broncos Chargers team would be
but but they beefed up the other three
teams last night in round one Chris they
definitely did there's a lot of talented
Mike the West I think rules in both
conferences right now you know I just
look at the AFC West and I think you
know there's a lot of teams on the rise
there I mean of course the Chargers were
12 and 4 only two years ago so let's not
forget that there's a lot of talent on
that team
you know the Broncos are building
something the Raiders are close so we
saw them lose some close games last year
or two so I think the AFC West and the
competition level they're gonna be more
of a pain in the butt for the Chiefs
Chiefs are still the king but man that's
that's gonna be some tough fought
division the NFC East also picked up a
couple of receivers in round one see
deal and the
Homa wideout fell all the way into the
Cowboys clutches at number 17 I still
feel like Jerry Jones is trying to make
up for passing on Randy Moss 22 years
later but when a guy like Stevie Lam is
there at 17 Chris you got to take him
you got to you know I you know I I don't
know what happened here you know I'm I'm
shocked at ya John Gurdon didn't take
see deal and you know I would have
thought the Raiders probably wouldn't
even expected see deal and to still be
on the board and they would go with him
but CD lamb to me was the slam-dunk best
receiver in the draft
there's just nothing he can't do sighs
route running 5050 catches the best with
his the ball in his hand and it's not
even close you know so now man Dallas
with that offensive line and a bari
Cooper and dak Prescott and of course
Ezekiel Elliott and CD lamb to go with
it I mean that's just unbelievable the
fact that they got him at number 17 is
unreal and you know III heard or saw a
quote from Jerry Jones you know I think
they wanted to trade down but I don't
think they expected that guy to be on
the board still when he was there so you
just don't pass up CD lamb and Oklahoma
guide this makes too much sense for
Jerry Jones and the Cowboys yeah it was
it was fun to see it happen is it got
closer and closer to number 17 I thought
oh they're gonna take CD lamb they're
probably gonna put him in number 88 as
well Jalen Rieger went to the
Philadelphia Eagles Justin Jefferson to
the Vikings and Brandon a you get number
25 to the San Francisco that'll be one
out of all the receiver picks in the
first round I will scratch my head there
but Jalen Rieger yeah you know the rumor
around the NFL was that Hallie Roseman
was oh what love did love jaylen Riegert
and I can tell you just from everybody I
know and not that I've talked to all 32
teams but this is about the only guy I
heard that even considered Jalen Rieger
as a first-round talent so I got
question marks they're gonna have to
prove this one to me you know I've got
to see it to believe it
Howie Roseman explained it after the
fact by saying that Rieger Fitz Carson
Wentz's skill set that's why they locked
on to jail and rigor and this is all
about having the help around the
quarterback that gets the most out of
the investment they've made both by
trading up four years ago to make carson
wentz the second overall pick and by
paying him like they did last year so
that's what hey right wrong or otherwise
we're gonna find out remember half these
guys are gonna end up being busts and
maybe it will be jail and Rieger on that
bust list or who knows maybe he's gonna
bust out in a big way let's take a big
break when we return we'll play a game
of fill in the blank right here on this
friday edition of pft loss
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports